and the honor of spending some time with
the ukrainian prime minister who's in
town
today and
he is meeting with some of my cabinet
members including the secretary of
treasury and others
and
we had a good discussion i've talked
about what i'm about to tell you about
today
as well as he was thanking the american
people for their support understands
it's significant and
was we talked about keeping everyone
together in terms of europe the european
union and others
in the effort to
stop putin's of brutality
but before i head out to the west coast
i want to quickly
update the american people on the latest
steps we're taking to support the people
of ukraine and to hold putin accountable
for its brutal and bloody war
russian forces have retreated from keith
leaving behind them a horrifying
evidence and you've seen it you reported
it your folks and by the way i i i don't
say this often but i think we should
give enormous credit to the folks with
your agencies that are on the ground in
ukraine in these spots and uh they're
they're really uh
i've spoken to several of them it's uh
we owe them
but uncovering these evidences of their
atrocities and war crimes against
ukrainian people is so clear to the
whole world now
now they've launched and refocused their
campaign to seize new territory in
eastern ukraine
and we're in a critical window now a
time where
that they're going to set the stage for
the next phase of this war
and the united states and our allies and
partners are moving as fast as possible
to continue to provide ukraine
the forces that they need the weapons
they need excuse me the equipment they
need their forces need to defend their
nation
last week i signed an 800 million dollar
package of security assistance to
ukraine that included new capabilities
like artillery systems and armored
personnel carriers equipment that is
responsive to ukraine's needs and
tailored to support the intensified
fighting in the donbass region which is
a different war than in other places
because both topographically it's
different it's flat it's it's not in the
mountains and it requires different
kinds of weapons to be
more effective today i'm announcing
another 800 million dollars to further
augment ukraine's ability to fight in
the east in the donbass region
this package includes heavy artillery
weapons
dozens of howitzers and 144 000 rounds
of ammunition to go with those howitzers
it also includes more tactical drones
in the past two months we've moved
weapons and equipment to ukraine at
record speed we've sent thousands of
anti-armor and anti-missile helicopters
drones grenade launchers machine guns
rifles radar systems more than 50
million rounds of ammunition had already
been set the united states alone has
provided 10 anti-armor systems for every
one russian tank that's in ukraine a 10
to 1 ratio
we're sharing and will continue to share
significant timely intelligence with
ukraine to help defend them against
russian aggression and on top of this
these direct contributions from the
united states we're facilitating we're
the outfit facilitating the significant
flow of weapons and systems to ukraine
from other allies and partners around
the world
like the s 300 long-range anti-aircraft
systems that slovakia recently
transferred to ukraine we are getting
them in there we won't always be able to
advertise everything we that our
partners are doing to support ukraine
and fight for freedom but to modernize
teddy roosevelt's famous advice
sometimes he will speak softly and carry
a large javelin because we're sending a
lot of those in as well
you know but we're not we're not sitting
on the funding that congress has
provided for ukraine we're sending it
directly to the front lines of freedom
to the fearless and skilled ukrainian
fighters who are standing in the breach
you got to admit you must be amazed at
the courage of this country the resolve
that they're showing
not just the military military but the
average citizen
men and women young young men young
women as well
it's you know the sustained and
coordinated support of the international
community
led and facilitated by the united states
has is a significant reason why ukraine
is able to stop russia from taking over
their country thus far
every american taxpayer
every member of our armed forces can be
proud of the fact that our country's
generosity and the skill and service of
our military helped arm and repel
russia's aggression in ukraine
to beat back putin's savagery that tried
to seize ukraine's capital and wipe out
ukraine's government the battle of kyiv
was a historic victory for the
ukrainians
it was a victory for freedom
won by the ukrainian people with
unprecedented assistance by the united
states and our allies and our partners
now
now we have to accelerate that
assistance package to help prepare
ukraine for russia's offensive that's
going to be more limited in terms of
geography but not in terms of brutality
not in terms of brutality
combined with our recent drawdowns it
will ensure a steady flow of weapons and
equipment into ukraine over the next few
weeks however with this latest
disbursement
i've almost exhausted the drawdown
authority i have that congress
authorized for ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month
in order to sustain
ukraine for the duration of this fight
next week i'm going to have to be
sending to congress a supplemental
budget request to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue to deliver economic assistance
to the ukrainian people
hope
my hope is my expectation is congress
would move and act quickly
i want to thank the congress democrats
and republicans for their support for
the people of ukraine
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and our unity with the ukrainian people
is sending an unmistakable message to
putin
he will never succeed in dominating and
occupying all of ukraine he will not
that will not happen
in addition to bolstering ukraine's
resistance on the battlefield we're also
demonstrating our support for the people
of ukraine today
the united states is announcing that
we've intend to provide an additional
500 million dollars in direct economic
assistance to the ukrainian government
this brings our total economic support
for ukraine to one billion dollars in
the past two months
this is money the government can help
use to stabilize their economy
to support communities that have been
devastated by the russian onslaught
and pay the brave workers that continue
to provide essential services to the
people of ukraine
you know these past weeks have seen a
terrible human cost of putin's ambition
for conquest and control
approximately two-thirds
two-thirds of all ukrainian children
have been displaced in their home
more than five million ukrainians have
fled their country
it's an absolute outrage
the idea this is happening approaching
the second quarter of the 21st century
is just
last month when i was in europe i
announced the united states would
welcome 100 000 ukrainians
so that we share in the responsibility
of supporting ukrainians fleeing putin's
war machine
we've already welcomed tens of thousands
of ukrainians to the united states and
today
i'm announcing a program unite for
ukraine
a new program to enable ukrainians
seeking refuge to come directly from
europe to the united states
this new humanitarian parole program
will complement the existing legal
pathways available to ukrainians
including
immigrant visas and refugees processing
it will provide an expedient channel for
secure legal migration from europe to
the united states for ukrainians who
have a u.s sponsor such as a family or
an ngo
this program will be fast
it will be streamlined and will ensure
the united states honors its commitment
to go to the to the people of ukraine
and need not go through our southern
border
we're also continuing to ratchet up the
pressure on putin and further isolate
russia on the world stage
yesterday
the treasury department rolled out
additional measures to crack down on the
entities and individuals attempting to
evade our unprecedented sanctions not
just ours but throughout the west
today i'm announcing that the united
states will ban
russian-affiliated ships from our ports
as they did in europe that means no ship
no ship that sails under the russian
flag or that is owned or operated by a
russian interest will be allowed to dock
in the united states port or access our
shores none
none